welcome back to cbs this morning there
were peaceful protests overnight in
kenosha wisconsin
after no criminal charges were filed
against the police officer
who shot jacob blake officer rustin
is his name he shot blake during a
domestic dispute call back in august
the 29 year old man was left paralyzed
from the waist down
the latest protests follow a wave of
demonstrations after the shooting
when some of them turned violent mola
lange is in kenosha right now and mola
the question now is
how is blake's family reacting to this
decision
well good morning gail folks here in
kenosha braced for
more potential unrest in the
prosecutor's decision
not to charge those officers as you can
see of business owners
boarding up their shops protecting their
shops so far things have remained
relatively quiet here in kenosha though
blake's family
as you asked they say they're going to
continue to fight
until they get justice for jacob now we
should warn you some of the images
you're about to see
could be graphic they allow a police
officer to rain down
terror on our communities
it's in just jacob blake's uncle spoke
moments after d.a michael gravely said
he would not
criminally charge officer ruston chesky
for shooting blake seven times
as americans and the citizens of kenosha
and the world as a whole must get this
right not just for little jake
but for the little jakes that's this one
pack gravely said none of the officers
at the scene would be charged as he
could not disprove
officer chesky's claim of self-defense
when he and the other officers responded
to a domestic dispute last
august the d.a said the officers knew of
a warrant for blake for previous
violence and described the struggle
during his attempted arrest
which included tasing blake multiple
times with no
effect multiple officers try to grab his
arms and secure him so he can be cuffed
he admits at one point officers were
trying to handcuff me but i was able to
get
up prosecutors say blake tried to enter
a vehicle holding a knife
cell phone video captured chesky
shooting blake in the back
blake's three young children were in the
back seat it is
absolutely incontrovertible that jacob
lake was armed with a knife
during this encounter jacob blake in all
of the times he spoke to dci
admits he possessed a knife we spoke
with blake's father about his son having
a weapon
he was moving away from the officer he
wasn't a threat to that officer
as illustrated by his back being pointed
towards the officers that is that what
you're saying
as illustrated by where the bullets
entered investigators say they found a
knife
on the floor of the car how is jacob
doing
he's dealing with his situation
appropriately he's he's
he's where he should be after being shot
seven times
[Applause]
then 17-year-old kyle rittenhouse is
charged with
shooting three people during the early
days of the blake protests with an
assault type rifle
killing two on tuesday the now 18 year
old britain house entered a not guilty
plea to all charges in a virtual court
hearing
claiming self-defense he remains free on
a two million dollar bond
issues of bail have uh remain in full
force in effect do you understand that
mr rittenhouse
yes sir well the governor has called in
the national guard to help manage
any potential unrest the department of
justice says their
civil rights investigation into jacob
blake's shooting is
ongoing meanwhile the officers involved
in blake's shooting
remain on administrative leave gail all
right mola thank you very much that's
another
bitter pill for the blake family to
swallow listen i know whenever
police are called to a domestic
disturbance it's always a very
thought to be volatile dicey situation
we all understand that
but it's hard to understand how somebody
can be shot in the back that many times
family says the knife was in the car on
the floor the police officers say
another story but
still he had a knife and they had guns
and he shot in the back shooting in the
back part is the very difficult